For this project, I’m going to show you
how to drop the “Love Bomb”. These homemade
sticks of "pampered bliss" will instantly turn
any ordinary bath, into a rich and relaxing
day at the spa. They’re easy to make, they
smell incredible, and are the perfect way
to show your special someone, just how much
you care.
To start this project you’re going to need
a box of baking soda, a bag of Epsom salts,
cornstarch, and a little citric acid.
Citric Acid is the stuff on sour candy, that
makes your face pucker up when you eat them,
and it’s usually sold at health food stores,
by the ounce.
You can also find it at ethnic grocery stores,
or other specialty food stores, under the
name of “citric acid”, or “sour salt”.
Now we’re going to need some measuring cups
to get busy mixing, and manufacturing. And
while you’re at it, round up a descent sized
mixing bowl with a lid, as well.
Start by dumping in a quarter of a cup of baking
soda, an eighth of a cup of Epsom Salt, an
eighth of a cup of corn starch, and an eighth
of a cup of citric acid.
Now simply pop the lid on your container,
and shake it as hard as you can for around 15-20 seconds.
That’s all it takes to get an amazingly
intimate mix. But you might want to give it
a few seconds for the dust to settle, before
you take the lid off.
Alright the powder’s done, so let’s move
on to mixing the wet ingredients next, and
for that you’ll just need a little water,
some vegetable oil, food coloring, and your
choice of essential oils for fragrance. Those
are at the health food store as well.
Now vegetable oil works great for this recipe,
but if you want to score even more points
with your partner, try using castor oil instead.
Measure 1-1/2 teaspoons of vegetable, or caster
oil into a small container, followed by 1
full teaspoon of water. Then get the essential
oils you want for fragrance and relaxation,
and drip in around half a teaspoon. Which
will be anywhere between 20-40 drops.
Eucalyptus is my favorite because it smells
amazing and makes your skin tingle, but you don’t have to stop there.
Try taking your aromas to the next level by
mixing 15 drops of Eucalyptus, 5 drops of
Peppermint, and 20 drops of Lavender for an
even richer experience.
At this point you’ll have a full 3 teaspoons
of liquid, and the only thing left to add, is a bit of color.
I typically use between 12-15 drops of red
food coloring, then blend it all together
with something like a toothpick. 15 drops
of red is enough to turn your bath bombs pink,
without having to worry about staining your
skin, or your bathtub.
Now when we mix the liquid into the powder
it’s going to start fizzing a bit, and we
don’t really want that. So to minimize the
effect, try stirring the powder continuously
while slowly dribbling the oils in overtop.
Mix all the liquids into the powder until
you don’t see anymore fizzing, then simply
slap the lid back on, and give it another
20 seconds of vigorous shaking.
With that final step, our explosive “love
potion” is ready, and we can move on to
forming them into sticks, of bath bombing
bliss.
Cut a piece of string, or paracord, so it’s
around 7” long, then tie a simple knot at
the bottom, as close to the end as you can
get it.
If you want, you could also tie a little “secret
surprise” onto the string, and have it pop
out in the bath once everything dissolves.
Now we need a way to mold the material into
sticks, and for that I’m using a piece of
PVC tubing 1-1/2” wide and 3-1/2” tall.
If you don’t have any PVC, don’t worry.
You can always use a toilet paper roll instead.
Cut a strip of paper so it’s just wider
than the tube is tall, then roll it up and
push it down into the center. And when you
let go, it should expand and fill the inside of the tube completely.
Now hold the tube upright on a hard surface,
and carefully spoon the pinkish compound into
the center, one scoop at a time.
As it gets near the top you’ll need to press
the mixture back down to the bottom, compacting
it firmly together, with something blunt,
like the butt of a hammer.
Fill the tube back up to the top again, but
before you pack it down this time, poke a
small hole in the center, and shove the string
halfway down inside.
Gently ram the mix slowly and carefully on
either side of the string, to help secure
the rope in place, then press the other edges
down after that.
This recipe will give you just enough ramming
powder to fill the tube all the way to the
top and when it’s packed down as hard as
you can get it, carefully move the container
to the freezer and let it sit for around 10-15
minutes, to help it firm up a little bit more.
While we’re waiting on that, let’s round
up a pair of scissors, a stick of glue, and
these fizzy “Bath Bomb Labels” I made,
which you can find for free, in the description.
Download, and print off a copy for yourself,
and cut out the one that best meets your needs.
Or use them as a template to make one of your
own.
Alright it’s been about 10 minutes, and
you can see how tightly compacted our “Bath
Bomb” is from all that ramming, so all it
takes to extract it, is some firm and constant pressure at the bottom.
The end of the hammer works great for leverage,
and you should find your package pops out
cleanly, and hopefully, all in one piece.
Now go ahead and remove the paper to reveal
your creation, and just like that you’ve
got a cool little Bath Bomb, ready for use.
To make it a touch more professional, let’s
quickly add a bit of glue to the bottom tab
on our label and carefully wrap it around
the side of the stick.
With the edges lined up, and the tabs pressed
together firmly, our “Love Bomb” is packed
with passion, and ready to explode.
These little “Bath Bombs” are so quick
and easy to make, you may as well spend a
little extra time manufacturing a few more.
I made this “special” version for my wife,
and it’s packed with a little surprise inside, for her to find later on.
“Bath Bombs” are great gifts, and are
designed to instantly turn any ordinary bath,
into a rich and luxurious experience, for
your special someone.
They’re made with love, and the coolest
thing, is they do all the romantic work for you.
Simply toss one into a tub full of water,
and it erupts on contact. Instantly infusing
the bath with color, fragrance, and relaxation.
It energetically bubbles and fizzes away,
because the citric acid reacts with the baking
soda, to rapidly release carbon dioxide gas.
When the fizzling finally settles down after
about a minute, there will be billions of
tiny little droplets left glimmering and sparkling
on the surface of the water, and for a moment
in time your love will find herself in a blissful
utopia, feeling relaxed, rejuvenated, and appreciated.
And if there’s something hidden inside,
like perhaps a small piece of jewelry, it’ll
give her one final surprise, right when she
least expects it.
Well now you know how to use simple and common
ingredients from around the house, to make
a rich and luxurious “Bath Bomb”, for
the love of your life.
By the way, if you don’t want your Bath
Bombs to be pink, simply make them a different color instead.
I made a blue batch and used a novelty ice
cub mold, to make an exploding “Death Star”
for my kids. Which for some reason, suddenly
makes bath time the coolest thing to do.
Well that’s it for now. If you liked this
project, perhaps you’ll like some of my others.
Check them out at www.thekingofrandom.com